john stamos continues to mourn his best
friend bob saget the actor reflects on
twitter about how difficult it's been
since the late comedian's death which
happened unexpectedly sunday after he
was found unresponsive in a florida
hotel room john writes the mornings are
hard middle of the day comes in waves
mostly bad night time is hard i miss
getting a text from him right now me
answering him saying he's too tired to
respond me saying then why'd you text me
so early and on friday the full house
star tweeted yet another heartbreaking
message sharing the serenity prayer and
writing today will be the hardest day of
my life et has learned that a private
memorial service for bob will be held
friday in los angeles
you're loving teddy bear
put a chain around my neck and leave me
anywhere the tributes to bob have been
pouring in all week john previously
shared an image with bob on instagram
along with a lengthy caption writing
quote i'm not ready to accept that he's
gone i'm not going to say goodbye yet
i'm going to imagine him out there still
on the road doing what he loves with all
his heart and humor jon emotionally
concludes his post i'm just not ready to
say goodbye yet maybe tomorrow maybe but
he's not the only full house co-star and
good friend having a hard time with
bob's death dave coulier is grieving too
on thursday the actor shared never
before seen photos of him and bob on
instagram dave wrote in the caption i
met bob when i was 18 years old i didn't
know then that two struggling stand-up
comics would end up being brothers
forever i wish i could lean on you right
now through all these tears i love you
bob touched the lives of everyone around
him with comedians like gilbert
gottfried margaret cho and tiffany
haddish opening up to et about his
special qualities he's always someone
who is so kind he would send me like
tell me proud of me
send me a message we would cry together
like that's my guy like that was my guy
haddish got teary-eyed talking to e.t
about the late comedian sharing why bob
was like family to her i met him when i
was 16 when i started the life factory
comedy camp so
um
he was always encouraging and kind and
you know like you know you would watch
tv shows and be like oh it's my dad i
wish i had a dad like that man he became
like this this he was like an instantly
like a father figure to me and then if i
don't know where like around the time i
turned like 21 22 he shifted from like a
father figure type to a big brother like
to uh
come on let's go have a good time come
on yeah but that was a beacon for me
that was somebody that was always
a you know he always listened he always
gave me comfort in my heart
and uh
me and when people would be like tiffany
you need to be clean tiffany you need to
be this tiffany you need to be that
he'll be like tiffany forget all that
you know he said the other word
you know that like you got to be you you
got to do what feels right for you and
he was one of those few people that
always encouraged me to be myself
[Music]